[Aplausos]
una serie de retropies y la semana
previo a la celebración de la primera araña
de gauguirno El mandatario sobre frion
Reves la cámara de diputados Reccia il
está en el proyector de fitness
Central del programa sugovierno
prevé un aumento progresivo de los
en esta dispara igual
con la pelicula definance nuevos
pensiones direciosociales y de Educación de
Salut esta fue la segunda der Rota delle
Ejecutivo chileno La primera ocurrió el
Marco de septiembre de los spielventidos
Cuando es el 60 idosportsiento de la
vaciando su bala una bala
nueva constitución
El 4 de septiembre sí en dos tambals o
silencio al gobierno si un terremoto que
el africano así llamado el punto
texto politico que eso esta instalado
mientras espero
que obtuve interior de Gauguin
estas tres crisis despiden al gobierno
la del conflicto mapuche y en el sur
del país de donde proviene la población india
llama desdessia años la devolución
de la Sierra San sestries vienes el
el presidente vía criticó la
militarización de sonar parte de
anterior gobierno de un Héroe de siento
30° subamos juntos el regreso de la
sin embargo, no pienses en todo Sesto
choque en tiempos es la primera era
aniversario desumanda toque interior
También con recuperación de synnosde
economico con una caida de la inflacion
y el Control del dessempleo en un
fortalecimiento del peso relativo de
ver sexo